welcome back everyone to my round three
recap from Buell I just finished the
game against Dr adochio and this is the
first opponent so far for me this
tournament who is not a junior uh my
first two opponents were under the age
of 18. uh very underrated kids uh this
opponent I think his fide profile says
he was born sometime in the 1960s but
we're going to see that he's still a
very strong player and this was
definitely a really interesting and
heart-fought battle
now this game featured some cool opening
preparation which we'll get into but
let's start with the first few moves uh
he played D4
and I played D5 and I noticed in his
first round game he played the Queen's
Gambit declined exchange variation uh so
I just opted to repeat what he did in
round one but I played a slightly
different and slightly offbeat variation
after C6 Pawn E3 I played the fifth most
common move here if we see in the
database most common moves are Bishop E7
and Bishop to F5 if I played the move
Bishop to D6
and if you follow my contents closely or
if you watched like my previous Recaps
or watch me play online uh you'll maybe
know that I've played this move a lot in
the past and I'm actually working on a
course that's going to cover this line
and basically a whole repertoire for
black against D4 so I've been studying a
lot of lines in this variation recently
in preparation for my course but also
just in preparation for various
opponents and uh this is not so common
because it does look a little bit
awkward for black to leave the pin
against the Knight but this is a more
active way of playing and we're going to
see a lot of just active potential for
black going into the middle game
so he played very naturally Bishop D3 I
play H6 Bishop H4 castle and queen C2 so
this is um still very much within my
realm of preparation I play Rook to E8
which is basically the most flexible
move putting the Rook on the half open
file and essentially waiting to see how
white wants to develop and the two main
moves here are Knight F3 and Knight E2
um he did start taking a little bit of
time before making his next move so I
had the sense that he was not in any
specific opening preparation he played
the move Knight to F3
and I want to note that I had this
position about a year ago against none
other than Magnus Carlson in the simul
of the opening ceremony of the sinkfield
cup and the video is on YouTube along
with another video of my analysis of
that game but I learned from that game
uh because backness absolutely crushed
me uh there and we'll see the difference
between that game and this game but so
far we're we're following uh my game
against Magnus so my opponent is playing
exactly like Magnus Carlson I played
Bishop E6 he castles I played Knight b87
he plays A3 I play A5 he plays Rook a B1
and
um this is still the game I played
against Magnus and I actually have it in
a different chapter here we can see it
was the same same position after rook
av1 and in that game against Magnus I
played the move Queen to B8 which is
actually the only move that's been
played before in the Masters database
and this is one of the top engine moves
and it should be like relatively solid
even though Magnus went on to just crush
me um played a positional Masterpiece to
grind me down but after I lost to Magnus
I did some homework in the opening and I
did some just deeper analysis and I
discovered a different option for black
in this position so going back to my
game rather than repeating this line I
played another move that the engine is
very fond of this move rooked to C8
and at first this move looks a little
bit strange because it's putting the
Rook on a file which is just closed and
um it took me a long time to actually
understand the purpose of Rook C8 even
after seeing that engine will will spit
it out and I can just enable stockfish
here Rook C8 is the top move by a small
margin but yeah at first it seems like
black should keep the Rook on the a file
because after B4 it takes takes usually
it's good to have a rook on the open
file
but the point of Rook C8 is actually
prophylaxis against White's minority
attack
and the point is if white plays B4 in
this position which my opponent didn't
play but it's a major idea for white
black can take
and then play Pawn to B5
and the idea is to very quickly get the
Knight to B6 and C4 and establish a very
strong outpost on the queen side even
have ideas of Knight A3 later and this
completely diffuses White's minority
attack on the queen side and the reason
for having the Rook on C8 is after
Knights to E2 normally this move would
attack the pawn and gain some time but
in this position the Pawn's already
defended so I can go ahead and very
quickly get the knights to C4
so I hope this uh this makes sense Rook
C8 it's it's kind of based on some
subtle and deep ideas but I was happy to
get to play this in the game and this is
a novelty according to the Masters
database
here my opponent continued with Bishop
to G3 which is a very natural move and
if we compare this to my game against
Magnus after Queen B8 Bishop G3 what
ended up happening in the Magnus game is
I went for B5 and after Knight to E2 I
was really suffering with the c pawn and
just going had a few moves I was just
put under major pressure so going back
to the game I just played I had no no
worries at all I took on G3 and after
each takes G3 rather than playing B5
which is a very playable move here I
decided to start with a different idea
Knight to G4 and this takes advantage of
the fact that white no longer has a Pawn
on each file so H3 is not possible and
it's very difficult for white to kick
the knights away because if ever white
gets in the move F3 that would seriously
weaken the E3 Pawn so this is I guess
what we can call a pseudo Outpost that
is very difficult for white to remove
and Knight G4 just opens up some
attacking possibilities on the king side
for one there's ideas of H5 and H4 and
trying to break down White's structure
and another idea is to eventually get my
queen to H5 for the time being it's very
hard to actually get to the square
safely but if I do get to H5 then
there'd be long-term issues for whites
with H2 Square
so from here my opponent played Pawn to
B4 which is a very natural way of
continuing he's trying to eventually get
Pawn D5 and try and just weaken my queen
Side Pawn structure and in this position
I took a little bit of time because
originally I wanted to play Pawn B5
right away and have the same idea of
Knight B6 Knight A4 but the issue here
is white has the move A4 and I'm pretty
sure that this is a little bit
uncomfortable for black because B5 is
now attacked three times and I was
taking some time to calculate like if I
take Rook takes I could attack The Rook
with Queen A5 or queen E7 but after Rook
B1 I think white is achieving everything
he wants on the queen side and if I have
to take on A4 then I'm left with the
backward C pawn and my knight is not
getting to the C4 Square even if it
could get there it's not well enough
supported
so going back I did not play B5 but I
rather take on B4 immediately
and at first I was a little bit worried
about Rook takes before to hit the the
bee pawn and if I play B5 there's again
A4 and we actually transpose into the
line I just showed but then I realized
if Rook takes B4 I have a nice idea of
playing Pawn to B6 and the point here is
I'm not committing to B5 but rather
going for the expansion with C5
and if I'm able to get C5 in on the next
move then the structure is actually very
solid for black even though the B Pawn
could be a Target it's very well
defended and it's very hard for light to
stop Pawn Z5 and then eventually I can
get in C4 or maybe in some cases open
the C file try and exploit the queen on
C2
but probably for this reason of B6 after
Rook takes B4 my opponent took back with
a Pawn on B4
and only now do I play Pawn to B5
because now there's no more worries
about white basically destroying my Pawn
on B5 and I'm setting up the same idea
of Knight B6 to C4 and The Rook is
already well placed defending the
backward Pawn so after he plays 92 he's
not actually attacking the pawn and I'm
happy to play Knight to B6 and we're on
move 17 here let me actually hide the
notation to avoid spoilers but pretty
much up until this point I was relying
on not necessarily specific opening
preparation but it was a lot of prepared
opening ideas that all came into play
like I knew this idea Knight G4 I knew
the idea Rook C8 B5 Knight B6 and Knight
C4 so it is nice to be prepared uh
beyond the opening and well into the
middle game but having said that the
position is still very tense and we're
just past the first stage of the game
and I knew that this position is going
to be very much of a fight because white
has a very solid setup and things are
about to get
um very tense in the position
so he plays Knight F4 hitting the bishop
and now I do have to be careful with
ideas of white taking and if I were to
take back with Rook there's all these
Bishop F5 ideas that I did not want to
deal with
um I was calculating Knight C4 but I
didn't go for this because light can
take I'd have to take back with F Pawn
and then takes takes Queen G6 hitting
the knights
basically I saw this line and just
thought it doesn't look that great maybe
it's playable but instead of allowing
Knight takes E6 I just dropped my Bishop
back to D7 and even though the bishop
doesn't look so happy in the position it
does reinforce the pawn on C6 and it's
no longer a Target on E6 so he continues
with Bishop H7 check which I knew is an
idea in the position basically forcing
my king to either f8 or h8 I played King
h8 and then he plays Bishop F5 so as a
Nifty uh Nifty point to maybe slightly
make my king on a less desirable square
and now he's going for some trade and
even though it looks like he's trading
off a good Bishop for my bad Bishop he
is trying to perhaps weaken my Pawn on
C6 maybe also just simplify the position
so I go ahead and play Knight C4 and if
he wants to trade I might as well let
him decide whether to take my Knights or
my Bishop he took on D7 I took back with
queen and things uh did simplify a
little bit but now it's a game of the
the horsies the knights and I was
already feeling good about
my Knights on C4 and G4 I should note I
am threatening Knight A3 so light has to
be very careful here he played the move
Queen C3 so not plundering the fork
uh here I play Queen F5 so I'm having
ideas of eventually bringing a queen to
H5 and especially if he plays Knight D3
then I can play Queen H5 and just have
more attacking potential on the king
side so he took a bit of time here and
he played Rook 2 A1 I do want to note
that he was taking just a bit more time
than me took about seven minutes to play
this move and it's a very natural move
it's uh putting the Rook on the only
fully open file on the board
and I fight for the file Rook A8
and now we have an interesting kind of
staring contest between the Rooks
because white doesn't really want to
take my Rook because then I take back
and control the a file likewise I don't
want to take on A1 because that would
just concede the a file so for the next
many moves the Rooks just stay here
staring at each other and he started
with a move Queen to D3 here which I was
actually happy to see because uh pretty
quickly I responded with Queen to E4
which I have a feeling he maybe
overlooked this move
um but it's actually a very nice Square
for the queen because he can't really
take without weakening his position
tremendously
um the point being Knight just doesn't
have a good Square to go to 91 uh would
just hang The Rook on A1 and if he takes
first this is just a huge concession and
now if 91 I'll start cleaning up on the
queen side
and yeah if he plays Knight H2 here I
would I think I would just play Knight
to F6 and start going after the B4 Pawn
but on top of the fact that it's not
good for white to take on e4 white also
has to be careful to address my threat
in the position imagine it's blocked to
move my next move is Pawn G5 and this
would win a piece like for example let's
say he plays some nothing move like Rook
B1 after G5 the Knight is attacked
Knight's also defending the queen so
really the only try would be Queen digs
E4 but then I take back and I'm hitting
both knights with these two pawns so G5
is a very lethal threat and it's not so
clear how white just defends if he plays
a move like Rook D1 to over defend the
queen I have this Fork on B2
so he took a lot of time after Queen E4
only to return to C3 and while he was
thinking I was pretty sure this is the
best move and I was actually a little
bit frustrated that it's not clear how I
can punish the facts that white just
played Queen D3 and moved back and
seemingly lost a Tempo I was trying to
figure out how to try and push on
further for some advantage and I took a
bit of time to try and weigh my options
I was very close to playing Pawn G5 here
but I didn't want to overextend too
quickly because he has Knight 2 D3
and I was trying to calculate some lines
like if I play Queen G6 going in to H5
then he has Knight D E5
and I didn't want the position to
liquidate too quickly like if takes
takes takes takes I don't think black is
better here even though the epon could
be a Target I mean he's threatening E6
to unleash the check and now C6 was also
a Target
so I took some time calculating such
lines but uh I ultimately decided to
play a very non-committal move and I
just moved back to E7 and I was really
just trying to keep the tension in the
position given the time situation uh
we're still well before move 40. so I
wanted to keep the position as tense as
possible to try and just pressure him on
the clock now going forward from here he
plays Knight D3 and I play Pawn to F6
which does look a little bit strange at
first but the point is I'm preventing
any simplification with Knight E5 and
I'm also creating the square on F7 for
the queen because there are ideas of
eventually still getting the queen to H5
so here he plays Knight to H2 which I'll
admits I did not quite see coming and
after this move I realized the
deficiency with F6 is it took away the
F6 Square for the night and here I can't
avoid the trade of knights because my
knight is just restricted by its own
Pawns
and after he played 92 the first move
that came to mind was a potential
sacrifice on E3 and I took a long time
trying to make it work but yeah it just
doesn't work at all if I take on E3 I
think there's Knight F4 I did analyze a
little bit with engine after the game
but I have four would hit the G6 square
and the Knight is still attacked by the
pawn
so after a bit of a think I decided to
play the move Pawn to H5 not trading
immediately but keeping the tension and
now I make it so if he wants to trade
Knights then I can take back and get my
Pawn closer to the center also open the
H file I did have dreams of someday
getting a queen Rook battery and mating
on H1 but from here things do simplify a
bit he takes on A8 I take back and he
takes on G4 I take back and then he
plays Rook to A1
and yeah it seems like here I'm not
gonna have much attacking potential on
the king side I don't really want to
completely avoid the trader Brooks
because that would just concede the a
file
so here I decide to just defend my Rook
with Queen E8
and I'll be honest at this point I
thought the position is heading towards
a draw but I was still just trying to
keep any hope alive of having some
imbalance or just some chance to play
for a win and with Queen E8 I'm making
it so if he takes I would take back and
at least I do have one Trump in the
position
but he didn't take on eight he starts
with Knight to C5
and again oh no my battery uh I'm
running low on charge let me find my
charger
there you go this is my power converter
hey okay my computer will not die
and neither will my position
power converter or power adapter
fun fact I uh I forgot to travel with
one so I ended up buying it uh shout out
to coop
the store that sells everything
anyway what was I talking about
yeah he plays Knight C5 and we're still
in a situation where our Rooks are
having a staring contest
and I really didn't see a obvious plan
so I just tried to make a basic
improving move ponzer G6 I want to get
my king to G7 and maybe eventually play
F5 so here he plays Knight to B3 which
I'll admit I wasn't expecting but it
does have a few ideas uh for one maybe
he wants to play 95 and another idea is
he does control the A1 square and we're
gonna see how he tries to make use of
the square very soon because after I
play King G7 he finally takes on A8 no
more staring contest between the Rooks
but now the Queens are having a staring
contest
and I think when he went for this line
he may have missed my next move and I
was very very happy to play the next
move Queen to A4
uh keeping the queen staring at the
light Queen but now putting a ton of
pressure against the knights and the
pawn and on top of this he's getting
pretty low on time and we're still what
move move 35
so he has five more moves to make before
getting an extra 50 minutes
and here he took a lot of time like he
took most of his remaining time to play
his next move and his next move turned
out to be uh just a very bad mistake uh
he took on A4 now to be fair it looks
pretty Grim for whites because really
the only other move to choose is Queen
C3 after which I was going to play Queen
A3 and it seems very close to just looks
wrong in this position the knights
pinned to the Queen the queen is tied
down to defending the Knight and the
pawn
but somehow the engine says this is okay
for whites and maybe before I show what
happens in the game I'm just curious
the engine will say
yeah White's not losing but it's
uncomfortable and actually the crazy
thing here is
the only playable moves are King H1 and
King H2 because King F1 runs into the
tactic Queen takes B3 oh no my queen but
oh yes my fork and
um yeah this should be winning although
I was calculating this line during the
game uh Kimmy 2 takes King D3
but the Knight is gonna survive like
scene one and then if if here I move
here
oh it's a funny line here here and then
I can come to H3 and it should be a
winning King Pawn ending anyway going
back
uh yeah he'd have to play like a nothing
move and I thought there'd still be like
very good winning chances somehow like
maybe I I get my king to defend the C
pawn and then maneuver my knight yeah
I'm sure this this requires more engine
analysis to to see if it's actually
winnable for black but
um let's go back let me show what
happened in the game
I played Queen A4 he took and the reason
why this was a big mistake is after I
take back I get the outside pass Pawn I
hit the Knight and uh yeah it only gets
worse for whites from here after Knight
to C1 uh there's a very nice move for
Black Knight to D2 and it's possible
that he overlooked this idea when he
took on A4 but now the issue for white
is the king can't easily come in and I'm
just ready to walk in with my king the
light is always basically tied down to
preventing my Pawn from queening so here
he he played the move Pawn F3 like what
else to do but this just loses a pawn
after it takes takes takes uh and after
King F2 I played Knight to D2 and this
was move 40 so he did get the additional
50 minutes and once I played Knight D2 I
got up from the board and started
walking around anticipating that he
would take a long think and maybe use a
lot of time to try and figure out how to
salvage the position but at some point
as I was walking around he waves me down
from the board
trying to get me to come back because he
wanted to resign the position and I felt
a little bit bad that I was not at the
board when he uh he was ready to resign
but I came back and we shook hands and
he was very friendly after the game and
to be fair the position is completely
lost for white uh the problem is that my
Knight's coming to E4 so if he tries to
walk towards the queen side with the
king I would play 94 and if G4 then I
think I would just play King F7 and if
he ever plays King D3 I have Knight F2
winning the g-pawn otherwise I'm gonna
start walking to B5 and there's really
not much to do for whites so the game
ended exactly on move 40 after I played
Knight T2
and I think overall it was a pretty
clean game on my parts
and I actually want to show that engine
analysis of this game for those that use
leechas study if you ever want full
engine review of the game you can click
this button and request computer
analysis
and it will do some crunching
but I checked on the official broadcast
and it was pretty much a perfect game on
my parts according to stockfish we can
see here no mistakes and accuracies or
blunders 98 accuracy overall sometimes
you have to take these stats with a
grain of salt especially because the
engine doesn't reflect the whole story
of the game given what the critical
moments are and what the um the time
situation is
but it is interesting to note that my
opponent really just made one clear
blunder and that's all it takes to lose
a chess game chess can be very
unforgiving in this regard
so anyway yeah I think uh I think I
should be happy with my play today I do
want to thank Magnus Carlson for
destroying me in this opening about a
year ago and giving me the motivation to
study the opening even more deeply and
come up with this novelty Rook 2 C8
which worked out quite nicely today
so I'm currently one and a half out of
three it was a tough first couple rounds
but um I'm happy to at least show some
good form in this game
and do stay tuned for round four which
will be tomorrow at 2PM Deal Time 7 A.M
U.S Central Time uh be sure to check out
the twitch Channel twitch.tv slash I am
Rosen where Jonathan trance AKA vampire
chicken has been doing commentary he's
been doing an amazing job always full of
energy even after uh the four or five
hour games so do show some supports and
I'll be back soon stay tuned